I'm gonna show you my answer um firstly
I'll tell you the number and then those
of you can have it because there are
somebody who do can can baby can breathe
a sigh of relief however I'm just gonna
say when you have a look at a question
like this right your ability is if
you're not convinced of the answer
before you're told the answer and
absolutely know that that's the answer
and and come on so committed to it that
you're like no the answer is wrong if
you get told something different then
you don't really know if your answer is
the answer right so that means now it
doesn't mean a bad thing even you got
the right number but it means you still
got a way to go so the answer is 66 so
congratulations if you got 66 however
it's worth pointing out I can come up
with the number 66 by stringing together
a random series of like add this and
multiply that AHA 66 and you might not
be able to demonstrate why it is 66 okay
so um my three clues my three crews
started we'd come up with a simpler
version of this problem okay remember I
said to you if you have a simple problem
you can list things out there list them
out one of the wonderful things about
this is that it's sort of self-evident
you're like what there they are right
like I've got all the ways so you don't
need to necessarily worry about like did
I miss a typo did I look at it the wrong
way
I've got I've written down all the way
now you can't
despite Brendon you know trying you
can't write down all the ways at least
even with this like that's actually
physically possible but most people will
not be systematic enough to actually get
all 66 and not miss any and make sure
they've gone I had a Pokemon you came to
my head a Norco say okay so what you
should do instead is let's boil the
question down let's imagine if we had
something simpler right because then I
can actually care list them and then I
can try and use principles there to
convince myself the using
okay so what would be a nicer smaller
number of a deeper balls to put into
three label boxes now to keep things
interesting maybe you want to do this
with me I think probably a reasonable
number that's still gonna have enough in
common with the question that what
principles I gain out of it will help me
I'm gonna go with three so this is a
question
oops I should say labeled by the way um
the place where I got the special from
didn't say labeled which actually
changes question a little bit
this means I can tell the boxes apart
right there's like box one box two box
three or red box green box okay so these
can be distinguished but these cannot
know with three with three there are ten
ways there are exactly ten ways and you
can help me work out what they are let's
imagine you've got box one lost soon box
three we already had this discussion but
just for the sake of the record can you
have all of your three identical balls
in one of the boxes of course you can
because you're still placing them into
boxes just happen to leave some of it
okay
so try and think about this in a logical
way what might be a way that you start
start listing out the ways you could
place like how many here how many here
have been with you what's a nice logical
way okay yeah cool I think that's about
as simple as I can get right take a ball
there they are okay but as soon as you
write that down if you're thinking about
it systematically there are other ways
that are very similar to this but
different it up right for example let's
take the same group and put them all in
there or take the same group and put
them all in there good okay I guess a
way I could say this is this is all the
ways of arranging by using one of the
boxes does that make sense okay now I'm
trying to stay logical right and list
the madness systematic way if this is
the ways of doing it by using one box
how many ways are there if I you
jukeboxes okay so if I use two boxes one
of them is gonna have two and one's
gonna have one right last one has zero
okay that's the only ways to do it so
for example I could go to one zero
give me those now interesting I'm gonna
get four two zero one because again I
want at least assign a systematic way so
I don't miss anything right so I'm gonna
keep these the same and then swap these
and then I'm gonna have another two like
this right one zero zero one you see how
I'm trying to do this is a systematic
way so I don't miss anything I'm still
in the scheme of using two two boxes so
the last one grab a seat it's gonna be
two two zero one one zero happy are
there any other ways that I can use just
two boxes just two boxes that's it right
that's it
so I've got one box used two boxes used
how many ways can I use all the boxes
there's only one way right okay so this
captures that's it and like I said the
wonderful thing about a list like what I
think we sort of looked down on this
right just like what a pedestrian way to
do things but it's self-evident there's
no other way that you can do this one
box two boxes three boxes all the
options so then comes the challenge of
thinking well how can I come up with the
number ten in what ways can I work out
ten coming through in here right now to
try and get at the logic to try and get
at the logic my second clue my second or
third cruiser actually do have the same
clue
there to think about this not in terms
of putting bores into boxes but think
about the balls being already there and
ways to separate them into different
boxes right so here's like if you can
imagine this way here the balls are
movable right it's like oh wait where
should I place them and these things are
just fixed okay my second schema thing
about this is well what if the balls are
fixed and I'm trying to designate these
ones go in this box these always go in
this box let's Sarah
okay so there's at least two ways of
thinking about this
now gin so at this point I'm going to
pause and ask you to explain the class
how did you what extra ID did you
introduce because this is just balls and
boxes but you had a whole extra idea
that helped you think about this what
was your way of thinking
just just explain what you did you had
more than just the balls to place you
had something else that you placed okay
okay so this is a new way of framing the
question right
there's nothing about gaps in the
question but we can introduce these guys
as our mechanism for saying okay some of
these will be in the first box some of
these will be the second and solving the
third okay for instance this is one of
the arrangements this is one of the
arrangements in fact it's the first
arrangement they can you imagine
everything to the left of this gap is
the first box right and then everything
in here is the second box right and then
everything over here is the third box so
this is 3 0 0 do you see that how would
I do this one how would I should do it
what kind of an way would it be balls
and gaps together
yeah very good okay look see everything
before the first gap that's what's in
box one which is none of them and here's
box two and then here's box three and
it's also empty do you see how this
works and you can say any of these in
this way and it all work okay so how
many objects my arranging I count one
two three four five objects five objects
ah but some of them are identical right
how many identical things do I have well
the these are all identical so three
factorial and then the gaps are also
identical right I can't tell the
difference between them all right so
that's ten that's ten yes okay now
that's not the only way you can think
about it you can think about and this is
the way that Lee's was trying to but
didn't quite get there you can think
about em I actually um I don't know if
you remember this when we did one of
those like what was the word I gave you
decisions I think it was and you had to
say oh okay how many ways can i range
away the D is to the left of them and or
something like that okay right so if I
fix these guys in place I can think of
that arranging the gaps now how many
places are there where I can put a gap
if you wait I count four one two three
four right
but there's a secret one is a secret one
how many gaps do I have to place again
how many gaps I have to gaps to place so
this is going to be something choose to
make something choose to I'll by the way
yeah we already established this is to
write something choose two now I'm
saying that okay you can put a he he he
or he are right but actually once you
place one of the gaps right like say I
place a gap here that's pretty awesome
let's place a gap there okay at the
moment what does this configuration look
like where are where are all of the um
the balls in this current configuration
this one is in the first box and these
are in the second box right what if I
didn't want to place any in the third
box right we're going to put it the
answer is I wouldn't use that gap that
gap I don't need right I've already
separated them into two groups
okay so I've got the first group second
group and I don't need to divide them
anymore does that make sense so I've got
one two three four five spots racking
put a gap and I have to choose two of
them and you will fly in fly see two
he's also Tim because that is in fact
five see - okay but we arrived at this
in kind of a different way right we're
arranging objects is a permutation the
order matters right but then you have
these identical things does that make
sense yeah at the very front I can still
do that right
mmm-hmm or this is a different
arrangement again right so I can use the
second gap or I don't have to I don't
have to use it yes yes yes that's
exactly right so that's another way of
thinking about it I want to play that
using that as my explanation but then I
thought yeah I I get confused because
then I'm like okay I place a gap and
essentially what you're mentioning is
like twice in two gaps together right so
it's like oh I've made a new position
right which is right where I am and it's
not done well it does need to be too
because I've put it here or here it's
the same that's the same effect right
but I think it's better just to say
don't use that it has the effect of not
dividing anything at all so you might as
well just put it so now you're ready to
tell me what the answer to the original
question is right because you've
understood the principle in a manageable
way what's different yeah yeah from
three identical balls I added two gaps
to that and that's what made it 5c 2 not
3 C 2 right but if I have 10 balls and I
still have two gaps then it's going to
be not Phi C 2 but what seats with which
I think you'll find is 66 and one of
them lovely things about this about
having understood the way it works is
that now I can say all right what if you
wanted to pick place them into um I
don't know 10 boxes right that wouldn't
be any more difficult for you now that
you understand what's going on
underneath whereas if you want to try
and go with cases you're going to be
sitting there for
okay please don't underestimate a lot of
people actually pretty much this is what
I mentioned before I don't I didn't say
anyone who actually said okay I can't
work with this question and understand
the principle right now or at least I
can't be convinced that my principle is
right even the people who have the right
answers still doubt it maybe I haven't
considered something but if you sort of
cut the question down to size then you
can say or Thor attentively no no I've
considered everything and it works the
principle works and then I can extend it
very easy that make sense